Isabelle sorante vous êtes romancière
essayiste à vous collaborez depuis le
début à Philosophie Magazine et l'un de
vos thèmes importants c'est et bien
c'est le vivant c'est le réchauffement
climatique c'est la barbarie rationnelle
vis-à-vis de l'animal c'est le mal que
l'homme fait au vivant mais se faisant
également à lui-même or ce mal est
dites-vous intimement lié à l'oubli de
l'âme elle oublie d'une dimension
métaphysique une dimension métaphysique
d'ailleurs qui affleure dans tous vos
textes ce mal est également lié à une
crise de l'imaginaire nous y reviendrons
et c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle
vous avez choisi la voix du roman plutôt
que celle de la science par exemple
alors que tous vos idées puisque vous
êtes également polytechnicienne vous
avez finalement choisi de donner à voir
ce que le scientifique calcule alors
cela est très présent dans votre
dernière ouvrage l'instruction
qui s'ouvre sur le souvenir de l'oiseau
la moko Cadix victime d'une marée noire
en 1978 dont la télévision retransmet
l'agonie vous avez 7 ans peut-être
peut-on commencer par ça c'est vrai que
pour moi la mokoka Cadix c'est dans mon
enfance la première
image du monde qui fait effraction dans
mon esprit et je me souviens encore de
cet oiseau noir puisque le
roman a un aspect autofictionnel ce
roman là en tout cas et qui
arrive à les ailes tout engluées de
pétrole nage dans un
océan noir qui bombe à moi mon âge je
suis enfant me paraît infini ce e
jusqu'à un rocher à visiblement très mal
on voit ses ailes engluer on se demande
à quoi il pouvait ressembler avant et
comme il ne peut pas s'envoler ses ailes
sont paralysées il décide de pour moi
c'est très clair quand je suis enfant de
volontairement se suicider et de se
rejeter dans cette marée noire et comme
à ce moment là les adultes n'arrêtent
pas de dire le mot marée noir désastre à
moko Cadix après coup j'ai vraiment eu
l'impression d'être initié à ce que
serait notre 21e siècle ça se passe en
78 mais c'est une initiation très très
brutale j'ai pensé à cette image tout au
long de ma vie elle m'a toujours
accompagnée et c'est parce qu'elle m'a
toujours accompagnée que je j'en suis
venu à me demander dans quelle mesure
c'est un peu comme c'est fait divers qui
vont nous frapper où tout d'un coup on a
peur de se mettre à la place de l'autre
personne et on se dit très souvent
pourvu que ça m'arrive pas à moi là
quand c'est un animal c'est un peu
différent parce qu'on va on se dit pas
pourvu que ça m'arrive pas et puis c'est
quelque chose de tellement étrange la
marée noire mais on se dit
qui a quelque chose de nous qui est là
et qui est aussi englouti dans cette
marée noire et enfin on le ressent c'est
beaucoup moins l'identité et beaucoup
moins fixe beaucoup moins rigide il y a
encore une identité magique et tout d'un
coup
on se dit c'est moi en fait c'est moi
qui suis en train de me noyer dans cet
enfer noir et
pour moi je crois que c'est un point de
départ de l'écriture et très
certainement aussi un maître spirituel
cet oiseau parce qu'il me blesse d'une
blessure qui est encore présente
aujourd'hui alors reprenons la
chronologie inscrite dans votre dernière
ouvrage l'instruction vous faites un
burn-out comme de nombreuses lécheurs
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un slasher c'est
ses indépendants qui cumulent plusieurs
jobs pas nécessairement des Bully Jobs
mais en tout cas qui qui sont cumulatif
et donc qui finissent par vous épuiser
Burnotte également lié à l'angoisse du
réchauffement climatique puisque vous
faites tout un lien entre la question du
travail de l'adaptation de la
performance et du réchauffement
climatique et à l'occasion de ce
burn-out vous cherchez des réponses et
lors d'une séance avec un maître un
maître spirituel vous entendez une
instruction qui va vous hanter que celui
qui cherche la vérité se mettent à la
place d'un animal conduit à l'abattoir
alors c'est un peu le début d'une
descente aux enfers au sens propre du
terme d'ailleurs puisque vous allez
visiter et éprouver partager
l'expérience de ce qu'on appelle une
structure de production porcine c'est à
dire une entreprise méthodique de mort
au nom de la rentabilité économique
alors peut-être commençons par la
question du du burn-out du travail ce
lien très très fin que que vous faites
avec avec justement la structure de
production oui c'est parce que en fait
le livre il est effectivement construit
comme ça quand
la narratrice qui est moi je veux pas me
défendre
rencontre elle est pas aboutiste en fait
je le suis pas belle dans une vraie
quête spirituelle c'est à dire elle veut
comprendre le sens quand on dit burnout
il y a quelque chose qui brûle et
l'impression qui se dégage en fait en
réalité pour elle et comme pour les gens
qui l'entourent c'est que ce qui brûle
c'est notre âme c'est un lien magique ou
vivant qui s'est perdu et que donc il y
a une espèce de course dans des couloirs
dans le métro il y a une espèce de
course permanente et c'est ce
crépitement de la course qui fait brûler
quelque chose et
il y a cette intuition que la réponse
n'est pas forcément à ralentissement ou
des vacances mais quelque chose qui a
voir avec
[Musique]
le sens le plus secret de la vie le
quelque chose de obscur de discret qu'on
est en train de perdre et en fait c'est
un petit peu le début du livre c'est un
petit peu ça son espèce de dérange
finalement elle se demande comment ça
vie va un petit peu se réintégrer
puisque il y a toutes ces activités il y
a cette énorme fatigue et la rencontre
avec l'instruction est fortuite c'est à
dire qu'il y a un maître bouddhiste qui
parle de d'une instruction qui en fait
d'ailleurs presque chamanique parce que
c'est presque près bouddhiste c'était
des maîtres nomades qui étaient
animistes qui l'a donné donc
quelque chose de très ancien ça me parle
à moi parce que tout d'un coup il y a un
lien avec la façon dont traite les
animaux et la façon dont on traite notre
âme finalement puisque le burnout vient
d'une manière de ne pas respirer vient
d'une manière de toujours courir vient
d'une manière de ne pas prendre le temps
de laisser reposer son esprit et on voit
bien que on traite la terre exactement
de la même manière on va cultiver on
laisse plus de jachère il n'y a pas de
mystère le même principe
extractiviste qui nous conduit à à faire
brûler des forêts à traiter le sol sans
répit à parquer des animaux aller faire
cavaler très vite il y a pas de il y a
pas de miracle on se l'applique aussi à
nous-mêmes et ça c'est la vision que peu
à peu qui est presque aussi une vision
chamanique mais sombre puisque
effectivement c'est une descente dans
des enfers qui ont presque l'air d'être
des enfers
gothique mais qui sont bien réels qui
sont les structures de production
animale
c'est finalement je voulais construire
le livre pour que au début on voit la
course des humains dans la ville après à
la course des animaux qui sont enfermés
dans ces villes obscures ces villes sans
nom qui ont presque les mêmes dimensions
que nos villes mais qui sont sur des
départementales qui sont toujours cachés
et finalement dans la vie animale on
comprend ce qui se passe dans la vie
humaine c'est comme un concentré de du
mal qu'on fait du mal qu'on se fait à
nous-mêmes du mal qu'on fait aux autres
êtres vivants aux animaux non-humains et
se mettre animal du début qui est cet
oiseau qui est finalement pris dans
notre pollution dans notre marée noire
c'est vraiment comme une matérialisation
du mal la marée noire et bien finalement
se mettre est en écho avec ses autres
maîtres qui vont être ces pauvres
animaux qui sont enfermés dans la
structure de production et qui est aussi
nous regarde en nous demandant
pourquoi comment et dans ces regards il
se passe quelque chose alors vous vous
avez fait l'expérience de ces structures
de production ou les avez observé vous
racontez cette expérience très étrange
de dire en fait ce dont on s'aperçoit
c'est que les animaux nous voient aussi
c'est pas seulement nous qui les voyons
et encore c'est rare qu'on puisse les
voir puisque à part les caméras de L214
ou ceux qui travaillent personne ne sait
vraiment comment ça se passe donc vous
les donnez à voir mais en même temps
vous raconter aussi que tout à coup on
est vu par les animaux c'est quoi cette
c'est notre identité qui bascule en fait
parce que je pense que notre identité
elle se construit avec les regards que
les autres vont poser sur nous et là
tout d'un coup il y a un côté pour moi
conte de fées dans cette expérience
c'est à dire que en fait je rentre
presque miraculeusement parce que au
tout départ il y a l'instruction mais
très vite je me dis tiens ça pourrait
faire un roman intéressant et puis je
parle pas trop de la motivation social
qui est spirituelle parce que je veux
dire on va me prendre pour une folle de
vouloir suivre une instruction d'aller
jusque là donc je la je la tais je la
garde secrète et je les gardais secrète
très longtemps jusqu'à l'écriture de
livre pour dire bon voilà je fais un
roman je
rassure et en toute honnêteté les les
Porcher qui travaillent à l'intérieur
puisque je suis pas journaliste je suis
vraiment le compteur de finalement ce
tout petit groupe parce que si ces
villes animales elles sont énormes genre
il y a 15000 ou 20 000 animaux à cause
de l'informatisation il y a juste cinq
ou six personnes qui gèrent ce mot
atroce qui qui gère tous ces animaux et
qui les produisent le mot produire il
réduit la vie et la mort quand ils
disent voilà on produit 25000 animaux
par an et ben produire ça veut dire on
les fait naître on les engraisse et on
les fait mourir et donc le mot produire
tout d'un coup je me rends compte en
fait il condense la vie et la mort qui
qui a plus rien d'autre que le poids de
viande et quand on rentre à l'intérieur
donc les humains sont en minorité
puisque il y a cinq ou six Porcher pas
plus qu'en plus chacun c'est évidemment
un travail segmenté comme très souvent
ce qui a rapport au mal et segmenté de
manière à ce que ce ne soit la
responsabilité de personne puisque
finalement personne ne tue il y a des
personnes qui mettent au monde il y a
des personnes qui vont nourrir les
petits des personnes qui vont engraisser
des personnes qui vont engraisser un peu
plus des personnes qui vont conduire le
camion et des machines et à la fin une
personne qui est le Seigneur
mais ce n'est pas le Seigneur tout seul
qui qui tue c'est nous tous en réalité
et donc quand tout d'un coup on déambule
dans ses couloirs
et quand on rentre dans une des salles
où par exemple il va y avoir
200 fruits qui sont dans des dans des
cages en fer et qui toutes les têtes se
tournent vers vous
alors il se passe quelque chose où on
comprend que
on est aussi ce qu'elle voit quoi c'est
est-ce que c'est un gardien est-ce que
c'est un tortionnaire est-ce que c'est
quelqu'un qui potentiellement pourrait
les libérer et je pense que c'est à ce
genre de bâtiment qui est salutaire en
réalité qu'on a accès justement si on
revient à l'instruction à se mettre aux
anciens pourquoi ils se retirait dans la
nature pourquoi on cherche à mener une
vie hérétique au milieu des arbres et
des oiseaux il me semble que c'est parce
que le vivant dans son entier dans son
rapport au non humain va
donner une clé sur la véritable
amplitude de notre identité d'ailleurs
il y a un très beau livre de texte zen
qui s'appelle je ne suis pas un être
humain qui est qui est un recueil de
Cohen donc en fait il y a quelque chose
ou d'autres titres comme ça au moins
vouloir apport des textes qui disent il
y a plus que ce qu'on croit et tout d'un
coup là on n'est pas sur les hauts
plateaux de l'Himalaya on n'est pas dans
une forêt on n'est pas dans les lieux
habituels ou les ermites depuis que
l'humanité existe on coutume de se
retirer pour se regarder dans le miroir
du non humain qui est peut-être le
miroir le plus magique le plus sacré qui
existe mais pourtant il y a un miroir et
qui est un miroir du non humain qui au
lieu d'être celui de la mystique et
celui de l'enfer et c'est très troublant
parce que moi je me demande mais que
voit-elle
ces femelles enfermés et ce qu'elle voit
c'est la vérité elles sont quand même
250 moi je suis seule donc ce qu'elle
voit à ce moment-là me définit d'une
certaine façon et à se mettre à crier et
c'est très mystérieux je ne sais pas je
ne serai jamais ce qu'elle voit à la
fois c'est désespérant parce que je
mesure toute la responsabilité qu'on
porte collectivement sur l'existence de
ces structures et sur le fait d'avoir
créé des enfers finalement et à la fois
elles ouvrent
cette ouverture je pense que vise la
philosophie que vise les religions cette
ouverture dont on dit c'est tout d'un
coup il y a une grande amplitude moi
pour moi elle se produit à ce moment-là
donc il y a quelque chose aussi qu'elle
me donne où elles sont des maîtres pour
moi mais en même temps la critique qui
pourrait inflorer serait celle du
soupçon d'anthropomorphisme comment
comment on répond à cela alors je crois
que j'ai deux réponses à ça
c'est que je crois d'abord que
l'anthropomorphisme c'est aussi une
manière de de réfléchir qu'on va
projeter sur plein d'endroits par
exemple en biologie quand il y a eu
souvent d'ailleurs on s'est rendu compte
d'ailleurs que c'était pas vrai cette
image des spermatozoïdes qui se
battaient pour conquérir la princesse
ovules c'est très anthropomorphique et
personne ne va jamais rien dire quand il
s'agit de d'animer ou de faire parler
des principes ou des choses pédagogiques
là on va pas dire c'est drôlement
anthropomorphique et un petit peu en
plus je dirais macho quoi là on dit rien
mais tout d'un coup c'est gênant en fait
c'est pas l'anthropomorphisme qui gêne
c'est de se dire ces animaux ils nous
voient ils ont une sensibilité je crois
aussi que l'anthropomorphisme ce serait
de plaquer un discours de voler la
parole à ceux qui ne l'ont pas d'ouvrir
de dire on peut les écouter moi je suis
plus je crois dans une dans une
conviction finalement animiste je crois
que ces animaux ont un esprit un esprit
sacré je crois qu'ils ont une âme je
crois qu'ils ont une subjectivité
laquelle je ne sais pas donc je fais des
hypothèses comme quand je construis un
personnage dans un roman ou comme quand
j'imagine ce que ce qu'un animal humain
pourrait penser mais je crois que le
véritable anthropomorphisme qui est
dangereux c'est que c'est de croire
qu'on sait et donc de se dire voilà je
suis certaine que il me semble que les
je dirais les communicants des
structures de production
ou même une partie des de nos décideurs
des économistes quand ils décident
abruptement qu'un animal ne ressent pas
ne comprend rien qu'on n'est pas en
train de lui faire non seulement
un mal physique mais qu'on lui fait
aussi en fait on lui fait aussi un mal
psychique et il me semble que c'est une
forme je dirais aussi
d'anthropomorphisme en tout cas de de
décision subjective qui n'a pas à être
de dire que on ne leur fait pas un mal
psychique de décider pour eux qu'en fait
c'est des bouts de bois qui ressentent
rien qui comprennent rien et je crois
que derrière le reproche
d'anthropomorphisme il y a la grande
peur qu'on soit en train finalement de
faire du mal à des personnes qui s'en
rendent compte
et moi je crois que les animaux sont des
personnes qui se rendent compte qui sont
ces mêmes pas défigurés le mot parce que
le mot défiguré s'applique au visage
mais c'est
des prix de leur être des faits et ils
s'en rendent compte alors cette question
quand même de se mettre à la place 2 qui
est à la fois
fascinante parce que c'est le grand mot
d'ordre politique arrivé à comprendre le
point de vue d'autrui et à l'intégrer
d'une certaine manière c'est un peu la
pensée élargie de Kante c'est aussi ce
que fustige par exemple tout les
critiques de l'appropriation culturelle
et ça alors comment on situe pour dire
que être à la place de c'est justement
un geste d'élargissement un geste
d'intégration un geste de compréhension
et non pas un geste d'appropriation et
bien elle est super cette question parce
que c'est je crois qu'on est au cœur du
sujet c'est pour ça qu'elle est gênante
etc moi je crois que être à la place de
au départ quand je commence à pratiquer
l'instruction je me dis je pense aux
mots compassion empathie et très vite je
me rends compte que c'est plus plus que
ça parce qu'on peut justement très bien
se mettre à la place de quelqu'un pour
le faire souffrir ou ou justement pour
calculer comment le manipuler donc c'est
pas forcément se mettre à la place de
c'est avant la compassion avant la
pâtisserie c'est comme pour moi c'est le
mouvement élémentaire c'est comme la
tombe quoi c'est l'atome de la de
l'esprit c'est l'atome de de comment se
servir de l'esprit c'est aussi ce qu'on
fait évidemment en écrivant et je me
rends compte qu'il y a quelque chose de
magique dedans parce que très vite quand
on s'entraîne à faire ça
on s'aperçoit d'abord que quand c'est
interdit de le faire comme c'est
interdit par exemple à l'intérieur des
structures de production animale on va
dire au Porcher surtout
pas à leur place toute façon ne
t'attache pas et vous mourir c'est que
des machines etc c'est de
l'anthropomorphisme et c'est très
suspect en fait un interdit de d'exercer
ce droit Marguerite Yourcenar dans les
notes sur les mémoires d'Adrien appelle
ça la magie sympathique en plus elle le
met en Italie je ne sais plus la phrase
exacte mais elle dit un pied dans les
rudes l'autre dans la magie ou plus
exactement dans cette magie sympathique
qui consiste à se mettre à la place de
d'un personnage et quand je découvre
cette citation je me dis que ou quand je
la retrouve plutôt parce que c'est
souvent les choses qu'on les a vu une
fois et on sait qu'un jour elles vont
nous concerner je me dis mais mon Dieu
si Marguerite Yourcenar a écrit magie
sympathique et si elle a éprouvé le
besoin de le mettre en italique
c'est que il y a quelque chose là de
magique effectivement mais pas au sens
magie
illusionniste mais la vraie magie la
grande magie de l'esprit on retrouve des
choses de ce genre dans des passages du
journal du voleur de Jean Genet donc
c'est lié à la littérature puisque
finalement la littérature c'est un
entraînement à la magie en cela la
littérature comme vous l'avez dit
politique puisque c'est quand on se met
à la place d'un personnage qu'on soit du
côté de l'écrivain ou du côté du lecteur
on est en train de faire un acte
politique on entraîne sa magie
et la question d'appropriation
culturelle elle est justement
bouleversante parce que à la fois moi je
comprends ce qu'ils peuvent faire se
reproche parce que c'est des personnes
qu'on a réduite au silence et tout d'un
coup on parle à leur place donc c'est
insupportable je crois que s'emparer de
sa de sa capacité à la magie sympathique
c'est aussi finalement pour moi c'est
comme ça que j'entends les
revendications sur l'appropriation
culturelle c'est de dire je veux parler
en mon nom je veux moi aussi me mettre à
la place des autres parce que quand on
est réduit au silence
il y a ce besoin à la fois de
s'approprier sa parole mais je pense
aussi de dire je suis capable de me
mettre à la place de l'autre et tu ne
pourras pas toujours te mettre à ma
place j'ai ce pouvoir moi aussi et
revendiquer cette magie revendiquer ce
pouvoir c'est c'est je pense qui nous
sauve et dans les structures de
production animale que moi j'ai vécu
finalement comme un mandala un mandala
charnier un mandala gothique un mandala
sombre mais quand même qui pour moi a
été finalement une expérience lumineuse
et bien les Porcher qui sont des
personnes remarquables un peu comme
certains militaires donc qui ont une
connaissance intime de la vie et de la
mort
d'instin vont vouloir récupérer la magie
qu'on leur vole c'est à dire que
puisqu'on leur interdit d'exercer la
magie sympathique à l'intérieur ils vont
souvent s'impliquer dans des actions de
bénévolat ils vont s'impliquer dans des
actions de conseil municipal ils vont
être pompiers ils vont et ceux qui ne le
font pas ne vont pas bien c'est pour ça
que je crois que le reproche
d'anthropomorphisme il est entre
guillemets suspect parce que c'est aussi
un truc de ne va pas par là je
t'interdis de te mettre à la place de
l'animal il ne faut pas y aller ah oui
et pourquoi est-ce que c'est pas parce
que justement ça cache le mal vous
vous êtes romancière donc l'imagination
est votre faculté supérieure si j'ose
dire et vous montrer très bien que que
le l'un des problèmes en tout cas du
réchauffement climatique de la crise
climatique c'est le défaut d'imagination
c'est-à-dire qu'on a des chiffres on a
des rapports du GIEC mais le problème
c'est d'arriver à les imaginer je vous
cite c'est une discussion que vous avez
avec une scientifique du GIEC et vous
lui demandez mais que faut-il faire
selon vous pour ne pas franchir le seuil
des deux degrés elle hésite et elle
finit par répondre c'est inimaginable
vous savez on ne peut pas imaginer on
est incapable d'imaginer et un peu
auparavant vous écrivez l'interdit de
raconter l'histoire d'une autre façon
d'une autre façon que par les chiffres
bien sûr comme si les économistes les
techniciens les gestionnaires étaient
les seuls narrateurs autorisés alors où
sont passés les autres
oui c'est exactement ça c'est à dire
qu'en fait il faut d'autres narrateurs
il faut se dire qu'il y a d'autres
possibilités de narration aujourd'hui il
y a une narration dominante qui est je
dirais une narration à dominante
économique on va vous dire ah mais ça ce
serait merveilleux mais c'est pas
raisonnable ça coûte trop cher ça coûte
cher ou on est pas chez les bisous pour
demain ok mais en fait avec cette
narration qui est extrêmement assez
chiante on pourrait dire que c'est un
mythe ou une structure narrative avec
tout le respect qu'on lui doit mais
c'est un mythe totalitaire puisque c'est
un mythe qui nous interdit tous les
autres mythes et c'est pour ça que je
volontairement j'aime faire des romans
au gars cette provocation d'utiliser des
mots comme magie comme le mot âme parce
que je suis consciente que ça dérange je
suis consciente de la ridicule entre
guillemets il sait quelque chose que je
veux assumer c'est à dire en faisant ça
je revendique une autre forme de
narration et cette interdit de
l'imaginaire il est il est très lié à
l'interdit de l'interdit de la magie il
est très lié
au finalement à vouloir
réserver on va dire une sorte de bulle
qui est en train d'exploser où il y
aurait pas une espèce de bulle acclimat
tempérée pour un certain nombre d'êtres
humains privilégiés et puis pour et puis
pour tous les autres et bien marée noire
réchauffement 50 degrés et surtout
défense de se mettre à leur place et
donc il y a un système là-dedans il y a
quelque chose et je crois que c'est
notre devoir en tant que romancière en
tant romancier et en tant qu'artiste et
même en tant que tout simplement être
humain ou tout tous ces êtres doués de
magie magie sympathique que nous sommes
de cette grande magie c'est notre devoir
de l'utiliser c'est notre devoir
d'imaginer c'est notre devoir de se
mettre à la place de très précisément et
justement quand on imagine les rapports
du GIEC alors on se dit donc ça serait
où ce serait des femmes des hommes ils
seront quoi le les maisons vont être
englouties qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
veut dire ça veut dire que par exemple
les personnes âgées pourront plus sortir
de chez elle il fait 50 degrés etc et
d'un seul coup quand on imagine on a le
on a le poids d'une émotion et en fait
s'il n'y a pas cette émotion alors on ne
sait pas en réalité on n'apprend pas
c'est que c'est comme ça passe très vite
ça ne s'encule pas en nous
le sociologue Beck dans la cité du
risque qui avait précisément pointé du
doigt ce défaut d'imagination qui était
l'un des éléments explicatifs de la
difficile prise de conscience de du
réchauffement climatique et de la crise
climatique et donc alors comment faire
est-ce que il faut demander au romancier
de prendre le pouvoir et ou de traduire
en tout cas les rapports scientifiques
qui ont évidemment aussi leur utilité
mais qui en l'occurrence sont secs et
sont je crois que c'est ce qu'on est
tout et tous en train de faire parce
qu'on se demande forcément quand on
écrit la fiction on ne peut pas faire
autrement que d'être hanté on y est on
n'a pas trop le choix vous voyez je
pensais l'instruction autrefois ça
devait être réservé à des saints donc on
imagine des saints nomades des chamans
qui tout d'un coup ils sont dans ce dans
ces dans ces étendues magnifiques et il
se décident de se mettre à la place d'un
animal qui est conduit à la mort et
c'est réservé à je dirais une certaine
élite spirituelle mais aujourd'hui en
fait le temps de l'instruction on est
dedans parce qu'on est nous-mêmes ces
animaux qui s'auto conduisant à la mort
les animaux qui cavalent dans les
couloirs aujourd'hui c'est nous c'est à
dire que je crois que l'instruction elle
nous a rattrapé on est dans un temps où
c'est on est au pied du mur sur ça et on
sait bien que si on n'arrive pas à
reprendre notre pouvoir de magie à
finalement accepter que notre identité
ne soit pas si fixe que ça qu'elle est
peut-être
ça c'est mon ma conviction mais plus
animée plus reliée plus étendue et avoir
où ça nous mène et je crois que ça c'est
un c'est un immense espoir malgré tout
en fait merci Isabelle se rendre on va
se quitter sur ces cet espoir avec
l'imagination au pouvoir merci Mazarine